i mean it's an amazing venue uh being up
here on the mountain
it's 70 degrees outside i mean what else
can we ask for
yeah we have four chefs announced now we
have james with this weekend we're sold
out next week we have justin hall from
main street provisions the following
week our saturday event is a
collaboration between cookie burger
latai and milkfish and then echo and rig
taking on the sunday event and then
nicole brazan doing um her wonderful you
know just magic on our fourth weekend
and then she'll have a brunch on the
sunday for our chef esther's kitchen big
success uh how does it translate to
something like this oh it definitely
does not like we we uh
we we uh
we are cooking on the fly here this is a
whole different uh cooking outdoors
cooking
in a tent you know it's a whole
different thing than in a restaurant
where it's controlled so
it's all about maintaining you know
logistics and making sure that
everyone's having a good time that's the
most important thing so far it's the
fried lasagna
from el salido de posta
and also
the real creamy cheese from
are adidas to die for
[Music]
[Music]
hi there
[Music]
what do you have there
um the ravioli i think it's the tartar
ravioli and um
[Music]
oh